I'd like to make a motion to itl House
Bill
1326 do we want to second
first I'll second
itk thank you Mr
chair yes um during uh testimony we
heard that um these permits are
primarily requested by municip ities um
the permitting process is already
expensive $2 to
$300,000 and there is a concern that
this would increase the cost and delays
further and it might um and that while
newspapers paper newspapers papers are
not as prevalent as they once were they
have an online presence that's often
linked uh to social media and spreads
rapidly to social media as as uh as
evidenced by the fact that a recent
hearing for uh one of these permits over
there was over a 100 attendees so I I
don't believe that this um bill is is
necessary and I think that it could add
cost to municipalities thank you so I
urge you to vote i' heel thank
you repres representative Dunn would you
wish to speak to your I think
representative der said it thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on the
motion
uh I will be voting against the motion
as the
chair uh I feel that uh there are there
were two amendments brought to
this committee that I think we should be
discussing uh the uh I think that that
that those amendments make the uh make
the bill
palatable and so uh I will be voting
against the I motion uh anyone else wish
to speak to the speak to the
motion representative
mchu thank thank you Mr chairman in the
interest of transparency I I agree with
you that notification is generally a
good thing the Amendments specified
economical way to do that with a
postcard and a smaller radius so I'll be
voting with
you anyone else wish to speak to the
motion representative Rong I I support
the itl because in the testimony and
even in with the Amendments I think the
greater concern is just getting the
public to go to meetings and I don't
think a postcard is going to do it I
just look in my experience in miramac
we're lucky if we get more people at our
deliberative session which is very well
communicated get more people there than
the people who have to be there so I
don't think um this notification is
going to uh bring more people into the
process a process that's already
established by Dees a process that's
already established by the
municipalities um to have people come
earlier in the process during the
planning board um you know review of the
project so I I just think this is
unnecessary I think it adds expenses
onto the businesses that want to bring
the project forward and I think it's
redundant with the existing public
hearing and notification system that
communities already have in place thank
you anyone else wish to speak to the
motion repres representative harb thank
you I'll make my comments brief I was
always concerned and even with the
Amendments that the bill is proposed and
as the Amendment states that there's no
statistical basis for the distance and
uh somebody's just making up the
distance I appreciate the representative
uh in his effort to clarify that and
narrow it down but he there's still I
don't see a basis for it so I will be
supporting the uh itl thank
you anyone else wish to speak to the
motion seeing none will the clerk please
call the
rooll yes thank you Mr chair on House
Bill 1326 motion itl represent harb
yes representative Moffett yes
representative Horgan yes votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes Representative mchu no
representative Donnelly
no representative Dunn
yes representative Vil yes
representative run yes representative
Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby
yes representative hoit yes
representative ltin
yes representative LoveIt yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative
frula
no okay that is 17 Ys three Nays motion
passes motion pass this
will
pardon oh I mean motion to itl passes
yeah motion pass motion to it is itl
they uh will be on the regular calendar
Minority
Report uh we'll let you
know I'll let myself
know moving on to House
Bill
1360 our chair recognizes representative
wolf I would like to move that house
bill 1360 ought to
pass second have a have a pass in second
uh there is a amendment to this bill
there is uh and can I move the amend at
will you will you move the amendment
please I think everybody got it
everybody got it at the first uh during
the uh during the
hearing yes it was handed um the uh
Amendment just changes a maximum speed
limit to a no wake
zone did you uh read the name the number
of the amendment the number of the
amendment is 202
4-0
H H I'm sorry yes oh that's they're all
h means
house okay um it's it's a clarifying
Amendment because figuring out maximum
speed was difficult a no wake zone is
very easy to look out and see what a no
wake is
that was on the advice of Marine
Patrol everybody's seen the seen the
amendment before
them okay any uh uh further discussion
on the amendment
wish discuss your second Representative
harb no I support the the amendment uh
that's what I got to say thanks anyone
else wish to talk speak on the amendment
if not will the clerk please call the
rule on
Amendment
04928 ought to P to pass on
0492 representative
harb I'm hesitating because we're just
taking a motion a vote on the amendment
I'm just on the amendment to passes
amended no just on the amendment I vote
Yes up to you yeah uh
okay uh representative Moffett yes
representative forgan yes CL votes yes
representative hey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Hoy yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the
chair yes 20 Z passes am passes now
ought the motion on the floor is now
ought to pass as amended you wish to
speak on the on the bill ought to pass
as amended representative thank you Mr
chair I would like to speak for a moment
on it um this past summer we had
incredibly high water due to the heavy
rains in July in particular on lake sopy
and there were several other Lakes
within the state that were affected by
the water levels um there was a need to
inform the
public that we should be not boting at
full throttle to protect the Shoreland
to protect the docks and to Pro protect
marine
life there was not a
clearcut wording in the Statue allowing
the commissioner of the Department of
Safety to put out a public service
announcement um put out electronic
messages to reduce the speed there was
never an attempt on this to find people
to be chasing them down Etc it was to
alert people what we ended up doing last
summer because the commissioner was not
sure whether he had the
authority we got the local police
departments that got their electronic
signs love your wake vot without awake
and things of that sort and for 10 days
we put them out and I would say there
was a 90 plus per compliance and what we
wanted to go give give the department of
safety and through them the Marine
Patrol the ability to do announcements
public service and electronic media that
there's a situation out there that needs
to be protected so I'm asking you to uh
give the authority to the Department of
Safety as the B
States uh well first repres harb to you
speak to your second
and thank you Mr chair I think the bill
as amended answers a need and uh that
we' have demonstrated and I support um
the statements of Representative wolf
I'm supporting the bill as amended thank
you representative veale
for speak on the speak on the
motion yes Mr um chair thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative of w
for bringing forward this bill I think
this is a really critical um need and I
do believe that there needs to be a
process for when we have these
incredible storms in the aftermath in
order to help people clean up and
mitigate the damage that they've had we
need the damage to stop during that time
so that people can regroup so I am
really in support of a to pass as
amended and I think the amendment does
improve the bill so again thank you for
bringing it
Forward is there anyone else who wishes
to speak on the motion of V to pass as
amended you seeing none will this CL
please call the rooll
yes on odd to pass as amended on House
Bill 1360 representative harb
yes representative Moffet yes
representative forgan yes CL votes yes
representative hey yes represent
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
veale yes representative rung yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes yes
representative Ryan yes and the chair
yes that's 20 to zero motion passes
motion of 20 to zero
HB
1360 passes ought to pass as
amended uh CC
consent okay no no no problem so it's on
the consent calendar on to House Bill
relative to P facility
liability representative rung for motion
thank you Mr chair I move ought to pass
on House Bill
14-15 uh do I have a
second I'll second second by
representative dun would you wish to
speak to your uh ought to pass to your
motion thank you very much Mr chair yes
I will um this bill is to hold those
companies that pollute our environment
particularly our groundwater with pasas
hold them liable for cleaning it up I
think you said it best Mr chair at the
hearing if you if you mess it you clean
it and you pay for it I wish this Bill
had passed in 2016 even earlier because
of the experience we've had in marac and
the surrounding communities where we've
had to our our citizens our rate payers
for our Municipal uh water system is had
to pay millions of dollars to take P out
that originated at the company and as um
companies are closing and
decommissioning this bill will ensure
that they have to do it responsibly
without any further contamination of the
environment thank
you rep representative dun you wish to
speak to your second yeah um I think
this bill is needed and it will take uh
the burden off the taxpayer for cleaning
this cleaning this mess up so I'm in
full support thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to speak on the bill
representative
fail thank you Mr chair and again thank
you for bringing this forth um just to
mention that there are several Bills
going through the legislature to try to
help um what we're calling the make
polluters pay um and so this is one of
them and I really appreciate that it
came
forward there anyone else who wishes to
speak speak on the
bill seeing none we on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 1415 will
the clerk please call the
rooll yes representative harb
yes representative mofet yes
representative Horgan yes the clerk
votes yes representative kealey yes
representative wolf yes representative
mchu yes representative donelly yes
representative Dunn yes
representative Veil yes representative
run yes representative
Kelly yes representative cson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Hoy yes representative L montin yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair yes 20 to zero
motion
passes 20 to uh uh House Bill
1415 passes
consent House
Bill
1268 we recognizes representative
Donnelly thank you Mr chair um I propose
that we do itl for uh House Bill
1268 we had several um
people come in and including Dees
contractor Association
and water oh sorry I make a motion to
it is you second I will second that Mr
chair now now you can start I I fell
asle I jumped ahead myself thank you Mr
chair for allowing me to jump ahead and
pause so um thank you uh again Dees was
kind enough to come in and
Express specifically how uh they have
strict regulations on especially these
large groundwater withdrawal permits um
they've had four um that they've had you
know requested but only one has taken
place um we've had the also the
contractor associations they have also
opposed this um Bill saying that there
is strict regulation around this and
that there is no need for um further um
prohibits and in addition uh we had the
ibwa association come in and they
representing uh Crystal Geyser um
there's an employment uh organiz they
are creating all sorts of employment uh
with a local vendor and creating jobs
and they have been a responsible vendor
in our community um and working within
uh our entire Community to help uh
regulate this and keep within the
guidelines of that Dees supports us
thank
you wish to speak to your second yes
thank you Mr chair I support the itl uh
for the reasons uh mentioned by
representative donelly and concur that
the bill is unnecessary thank
you there anyone else who wishes to
speak on the oh repres representative
veale thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted
to basically say that I think this is a
very well-intentioned bill um drinking
water and clean water is threatened and
groundwater is precious there is not as
much recycling as we would like and some
of the recycling causes plastic
Ash however I will still need to support
the it on this bill because I think that
we learned there were too many issues um
some of them that have been raised in
the property taxes of
$27,000 to the town was something that
really stuck in in my mind I put it
right on my paper workk thank
you anyone else wish to speak to the
bill representative L
Monte I I I will be also voting it but I
do think the bill raised some issues
that I think it's true that we probably
drink too much water out of plastic
bottles
unnecessarily but then again people who
are that lack clean and safe water do
need to be able to buy bottled water
and also for bottling companies many of
them not necessarily in this state but
they're actually using municipal water
sources not drilling new wells in order
to to bottle their water so I hope that
in the future if people want to oppose a
new Bottling Company and it's Municipal
they can deal with that on a local
level anyone else wish to speak on the
bill seeing no one
a motion of
itl clerk please call the
rooll on itl for House Bill 1266
representative harb yes representative M
yes 12 I mean 12
1268 oh
okay thank
you I read it back um representative
organ yes yes okay CL votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vil
yes representative rung
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoy yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Brian yes and the chair
yes that is 20 to zero motion
passes okay
obviously
consent
yep nice
okay house built 1268 itl and uh you be
you will be doing representative donelly
will be doing the the blur right also uh
representative wrong you've already done
the blur I
think on 14 on for not that we not that
we think
ahe and representative wolf on the uh
13360 you will be doing the blurb on
that
and representative
Derby sort of don't want to forget on
House Bill 12 next is House Bill
1277 uh this is
uh establishing committee uh to study
alternative alternatives for funding the
operation maintenance and repair of
state-owned dams uh chair recognizes
representative La
montain I'd like to make a motion of itl
do motion itl do we have a second
representative representative
Derby L montin you wish to speak to your
motion uh yes the Senate uh bipartisan
committee already passed a version of
this bill and um the sponsor was okay
with with it elling's bill in favor of
the Senate
version
okay representative Darby do you wish to
speak on new thank you Mr chair uh
representative La montine uh expressed
all of my points thank
you you're not
speaking please will was real will Derby
please show
[Laughter]
up wh up that mask anyway little bit of
levity all right uh
anyone else wish to speak on the uh
thank you Mr chair just just a
clarification the Senate bill is 549 in
case anybody wants to look got a not
there 7 Bill
549 thank you uh is there anyone else
who wishes to speak on the
bill seeing none will quick please call
the rooll on
277 yes representative harb yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Horgan yes yes votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
white yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
repres of Ryan yes and the chair yes 20
to zero motion
passes is it 20 to zero
yep okay conf CC right consent C
CC
okay now go to House Bill
1314 I recognize
[Music]
uh representative
mchu thank you Mr chairman I'll move
inter room study on
1314 13
14 do we have a
second I'll second Mr chair second by
representative harb do you wish to speak
to the
motion sure uh it's a good bill well
intended needs a little bit of work
there is an older development plan as
that we as we heard uh that we could uh
examine as well and not a lot has
happened with that so for now I think
the best thing to do is to hang on to
this bill study it over the summer and
make some
improvements you wish to speak to the uh
your
second no Mr chair I believe
representative McHugh set forth my
reasons for supporting interm study
thank you okay anyone else wish to speak
to the bill to speak to the motion
repres well I saw I was looking I saw
representative rung first and
representative
Bale thank you very much Mr chair I'm
opposed to interim study and I'm going
to be voting against it the bill is very
straightforward I I don't really know
what we would study it it's just adding
two sections to existing statute one is
to include drink on if you have the bill
it's on line 27 it's just to add
drinking water aquifier identification
and protection protection of our Lake
Rivers estuaries Forest wetlands and
Shoreline Uplands Coastal marshlands
wildlife habitat and then it continues
about Farmland conservation which is
already existing and um adding in the um
on the last page of the bill on line 16
adding an environmental threats section
which identifies environmental threats
from chemical and biological
contamination waste disposal inadequate
recycling opportunities in order to
address the cumulative effects of
natural man-made contaminants on our air
Waters and land and to anticipate
possible future threats to our natural
environment this is so critically
important to me because had this bill
passed before um a chemical plant was
permitted in the town of
marac this language would have prevented
that the state plan could have outlined
areas where that type of manufacturing
was and was not acceptable it's a very
simple Bill I'm not going to come in in
the summer to debate these two minor uh
minor paragraphs I think it's really
important when we're doing a plan to
include the consideration of our water
and our air and the environment so I
encourage um my colleagues to vote
against the interim study so that um an
OTP motion can be presented thank
you well
first that's right represent that's I'm
sorry represent thank you Mr chair um I
Echo what representative rang shared um
I too will be voting against the interim
study I think this is an important bill
that there is guidance that people will
need to use um and you know many people
that live in New Hampshire and visit New
Hampshire come here for the clean water
and it's really important to us to
address these Environmental
threats and to have this comprehensive
plan so that we can have a Common
Language across all of the Departments
that we are you know asking to mitigate
damage and to address environmental
concerns so I would like to as well see
a motion of aut to pass be brought
forward and again I'll be voting against
the interim study and I hope that others
will understand that and vote with
me representative Harve Bia you wish to
speak to yes thank you Mr chair I will
be voting for the interim study um just
two things I I was involved in a lot M
to master plans and I studied how Master
plans are supposed to work seen
litigation about master planning in
towns where as representative rang
brought up um she represent the
representative uh sort of touched upon
that if these regulations had been in
there then some sort of development
would have been prevented but you know
my understanding of Master plans is um
that you can't sort of legislate that
sort of thing if if we're following the
example of towns you know towns may say
that we want wish for a rural character
in our town um you can't use that then
to keep out development so I think
there's a little bit of misunderstanding
about what exactly this language is
going to do is can't and we still have
laws um which you know take precedence
that sort of thing also I saw some
outdated language in there um for the
protection it's seeking to protect uh
Lakes that's a bit um outdated I have to
just say that um we're not we're going
the updated language is to mitigate
issues concerning lakes and waterways
but not to protect them from anything uh
the idea being that it's sort of you
can't
you know mitigation is is the gold
standard and it's the standard uh as
opposed to protection which is sort of
more of like an 80s term so I was hoping
to update that language a little bit
thank you very
much
representative
wolf thank you Mr chairman um
representative rung uh alluded to the
fact that if this master plan had been
been in
place before the U construction of the
plant in maraman we wouldn't have had
this problem it's my understanding that
this plan has been in
effect for over 20 years and hasn't been
used
so I think we need to have interim study
to see how it's going to be used how
it's going to prevent the issue that you
were talking about I think it was
written and it's been on the shelf for
over 20
years finish to respond representative R
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative will for bringing that up
this isn't a master plan as
representative Harvey buolo mentioned
it's not a tool of communities to use
for their Community it's really a
statement that the state makes about
what our PRI priorities as we're
developing um State resources how how
are we going to make that consideration
um I'm disappointed as well as I'm sure
the entire committee is is that it
hasn't been implemented or used it's
been collecting dust on the Shelf but I
think that's a separate issue I think
that's something that we take up with
state agencies that use this but I think
the content of that plan needs to
includes include these environmental
considerations
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
I just like to point out that this is
titled the comprehensive State
development plan and it seems to me that
um the state development plan if it's
comprehensive can't it's it's lacking in
its comprehensiveness if it doesn't
include all our natural resources which
are critical to um our tourism trade our
many of our Industries and of course of
course um in considering the natural
resources we have to consider the
threats to those and the threats to
human health as well and that's what
this um that's what this bill does is
add those sections for consideration to
the
comprehensive um State development plan
so that the we can get guidance from the
state that can be shared to the um to
the communities and to others and to the
state departments in particular about
how to um how to estab how to PR how to
develop um guidance for developing um
resources um in a in a in a safe um
effective manner so I urge you to vote
itl on the um interim study so a better
motion can be made thank
you anyone else wish to speak
representative M thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative Darby and
representative rung for bringing up the
comprehensive fact it is a comprehensive
of plan and it's probably one of the
most important plans that we need to
protect air and water in our communities
so in that representative R and I
actually agree where we disagree is on
the Simplicity of the bill my concern is
how do we Define quote inadequate
recycling opportunities right what what
one community may find adequate another
community may find inadequate um we have
a a mixed stream recycling center in our
town and that might not be what another
town wants this bill asks for an entire
section on environmental
threats uh to identify environmental
threats I think that needs to be further
defined um it asks to anticipate future
threats to our natural environment so
apparently there's a crystal ball that
has to go in here as well which is
difficult and that's perhaps why this
comprehensive plan has sat on the shelf
for so long so there's a lot of issues
that we need to examine it needs to be
done in a thoughtful way to make sure we
get the best possible protections for
our communities and enable our
communities to take action to prevent
things like representative rman you
remember marac medals uh and our other
super fund site whose Name Escapes me
right now uh and of course our current
problem with that industry in the
northern end of our town so there's a
lot of issues here that we agree on but
I think we can all agree we need to get
it right and we can truly study it
improve this and bring back uh
recommendation uh in the in the near
term in in November of this
year so with that I would urge you to
support interim study um for the short
interum anyone else wishes to
speak representative
wol I would like to I am going to vote
for an N study and I think there should
be a SE added when we have major
developments that the the
Statewide development plan has been
referred to we have a thing in our
Master plans in town have you checked
with the police department have you
checked with the highway department have
you X Y and Z and I think any time that
there is a major
development somebody should read this
and acknowledge that they've read it so
part of my suggestion during inter study
and I I guess I just put myself on a
committee is to um see that it gets used
and not lay on the
Shelf anyone else wish to
speak um I have a question or two uh did
you read the uh old master plan uh that
uh the
uh the the development plan that
representative grassy handed
out
yeah thank you Mr chair I didn't go
through all of it I don't look at this
bill as really complicated it's just
adding some environmental factors into
the comprehensive plan I think some of
the ideas that representative wolf had
are very valid and if he wants to bring
a separate bill about that talks about
implementation and some other things I'd
be happy to co-sponsor that with you
this is just adding in environmental
considerations when the state has their
comprehensive plan um as far as
implementation responsibility anything
like that I think would have to be a
separate bill anyway and even with
interim study this bill isn't coming
back somebody still has to file it
actually
I I don't believe he did hand anything
out no uh so uh I only watch this on
YouTube uh and as his he had a plan I
did he did did did anybody read it old
plan uh maybe it did but I I it was I
didn't get a copy uh oh Mr chair when um
before I signed on as co-sponsor I did
skim a plan it is available yes but he
never handed it out did he and uh also
uh uh the if if in his testimony and I'm
not I'm testifying now I'm not or I'm
speaking not
questioning uh he didn't uh in his
testimony said he act actually there was
none at the State Library he found uh he
F actually found somebody I guess who
had a copy in stored away somewhere so
he found it in a junk drawer I guess
but the point is we're taking time and a
bill to discuss something that nobody
bothered to look at 25 years
ago and what's the definition of
insanity is doing the same doing the
same thing twice and expecting a
different
result uh
putting this into this bill right now
you're
changing that we have an we have an
Arcane
statute right now that is not that has
uh made a uh that which a plan was
developed and the plan has been just
shoved
away why don't why this is like having
amending that part of the statute right
now is like putting new tires on a a
junk car in the
it's we're spending time on a statute
that is not going to be operable until
maybe next year when he brings when he
when he said he would bring forth a bill
that would be the time to do this uh to
to do make this add addition to that
bill and not spend time and bring this
to the
floor and had and debate it on something
that probably might not even become a
bill it's with this is premature so
that's my that's my
testimony you wish to speak just to
respond um I love the analogy putting
new cars on a junk car but I don't see
that this is a junk car if you look at
all of the things that are in existing
statute looking at natural Hazard
section recre ation section utility and
public service section there's some
really good things in here so I think
this is like putting new tires on a
great car but we need to find the keys
and give them to the
driver the analogies are getting
great enough debate anybody else I won't
debate any
longer said my piece but anyway nobody
else wishes to speak on the motion
of of interim study will the clerk
please call
it on House Bill
1314 representative harb
yes representative Mett yes
representative Horgan yes cler votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vil no representative run no
representative Kelly no representative
Simpson no representative Baldwin no
representative Darby no representative
Hoy no Representative lontine no
representative lit no representative
Ryan no and the chair yes it's 1010 1010
motion
fails
okay
uh
representative representative Veil for a
motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
FN which is there a second I second it
second by representative veale
excuse me representative
R going back and forth you wish to speak
to your motion I do thank you Mr chair
um we agree that this is an important
guidance document and that it was made
25 years ago with the best of intentions
in order to be a really important
document there are a broad swath of
areas in this um bill that and in this
comprehensive plan that we definitely
need to update um I think over time the
last 25 years we've had a lot of
emerging contaminants and things to
address that section of the bill is
important to me um and we need to
respond to threats that we anticipate so
at the very least this will be
educational and once again I think I
made the rest of the arguments when
against the the last motion uh thank you
Mr
chair you wish to speak to your second
no I think I've said everything thank
you Mr chair okay representative
lante yes I think if um many of you
wanted to send this for interim study
you see some value in this bill and in
updating the the comprehensive State
development plan so an a toach motion is
just moving it forward so that the
comprehensive development plan will be
updated and many of the things that we
think we need to study more will
be worked out by the committee
developing this plan and it's time to
get the ball rolling on that so I urge
everyone to vote
OTP anyone else wish to speak to the
motion thank you Mr chair my my baptism
into my first year as a state legislator
has come
um
primarily um about by people that are
interested in this bill in then central
New Hampshire um the Lakes the rivers
the mountains the Lakes associations
like the sunap Lake Association Squam
Lakes Association I think we've heard um
that that the state Dees the state needs
to jump into the driver's seat here in
this very precarious time and and be
given a green light to to help lead uh
the legislature and the constituents
forward um given the Priceless nature of
our environment so it's not just about
water you know clean water in Southern
New Hampshire it's about this
multi-billion dollar tourism industry
it's about um um I think it's about um
supporting it's about dusting off an old
document that um perhaps has been put on
on the Shelf because the state hasn't
been given the green light hasn't been
given the resources to move ahead in
this really uh critical time with this
climate crisis that is affecting dams
it's affecting so many aspects of our
environment so I hope we can vote to
pass this and move forward and to um put
some teeth and some energy into this
issue of uh protecting our
ecology representative harp thank you Mr
chair uh with the motion for interim
study failing I don't find that this
bill is harmful and we all certainly
support protecting our resources lakes
rivers so with the failing of the
interim study I will support this Bill
thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion representative Ryan I'll be
voting to um support OTP if we we're not
making the the forward motion to protect
what is most important to us in this
state who
is anyone else wish to speak on the
motion I probably shouldn't even say
this but I'll say it
anyway I will support the motion because
I can smell a political trap a long way
away and so I'll support it so you can't
beat me over the head with it that those
evil Republicans did not want to protect
the our our lakes and rivers so as an
evil Republican I will vote ought to
pass well a clerk representative who
Youk thank you Mr chairman for a morning
chuckle um I've noticed I'm not laughing
I I didn't have have it in my file um
but I did have a look through the
comprehensive plan and I will also be
supporting the motion of a to pass as a
baby step although I I I find it a
little shocking that even some of the
sponsors haven't read this plan so
that's a little bit uh shocking um and
there are some things that need to be
addressed the good news is there's at
least two committees before this bill is
signed into law so we can clarify things
like inadequate recycling opportunity
and possible future threats those are
all things that we need to address that
normally are thoughtfully addressed in a
study process we don't pass
educational legislation right that's not
the purpose we pass legislation that
does good that takes positive and
affirmative steps with specific
Direction and we'll get that done in the
next two committees but in the in the
interest of of of supporting clean air
and clean water this is a this is a baby
step so I'll support the opop pass
yeah oh president you haven't spoken she
spoke go ahead yes thank I I hate to
beat this up and but um it's one has to
look at the purpose of the bill in the I
mean the purpose of the development plan
to begin with um it wasn't was it was
the purpose to cover every aspect of our
life here as in New Hampshire because
you know there are a lot of threats that
could go in here what about the threat
of contagion or other human related
threats um you're you're isolating this
and and pointing out lakes and and
whatnot but there's there's a lot of you
could you could look at you could look
at this from any aspect but what was the
purpose of the development plan to begin
with um it's really behe it really
behooves to have the um planning the the
office of planning to get involved with
this to see what's really
appropriate um obviously I second what
um representative rulu said if if this
comes back um I know that U Master plans
in towns cost about
$30,000 how much is this is a a very
large comprehensive plan like this that
sort of
encompasses all natural resources how
much is that going to cost that's quite
a bit so that's why I have a big
hesitation about this
R representative rung then
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
and I just want to get this on the
record I have tremendous respect and
fondness for you I hope you know that so
attributing motive that this would be
used politically I think is unfair thank
you representative Derby thank you Mr
chair just answering what the
comprehensive plan is about um it's
about uh helping the state um coordinate
across agencies to figure out um best
practices and where they should be
focusing their development efforts and
the environment is clear is clearly
crosscutting across all those areas and
so very applicable for the comprehensive
plan again this is not the master plan
right this just provides guidance on
what the equivalent of a master plan at
the state level should study so this the
the the comments with respect to details
that need to be in here just just aren't
applicable that's what the office of uh
the you know um growth and uh
development or whatever that office is
is responsible for so thanks I
appreciate the uh the support of my
colleagues um that are um will will
support this Bill thank
you seeing no one else will the clerk
please call the role I'm Lo the
best yes representative harb yes
representative mopet
yes representative Horgan yes CL votes
no representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rang yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative ltin yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair yep that's 19 to
one motion passes okay Mr chairman
consent it has a FN on it I don't think
it uh it has an indeterminate FN so I
think it has
Tod it's then determin
it actually what would having it debated
be interesting I don't want to waste
it all
right joh consent it's consent can can I
go on consent even with an indeterminate
actually uh if they'll they'll take it
off if they feel it's uh it's
required and Fin finally
house 1440 we got oh 1440 okay yep I'm
sorry 1440 uh chair recognizes
representative Harvey
buia and uh relative to establishing a
life jacket loner station program along
the marac
river um yes thank you chair I am making
a motion to
itl and
second second by representative L
mon any just we like to speak to your
motion just briefly um thank you chair
is uh I have seen myself that um a lot
of people they have been leaving life
jackets voluntarily along waterways like
near my hometown in Tilton in the samton
area
I've seen this um people hang them up
and just says loner so um also the other
reason would be the cost of supplying
these and then having them get
stolen uh which I guess happens too so
um that's my main reason for itl thank
you and representative lontine for the
for a
second yes I think this bill was uh very
well intentioned and I I found some of
the testimony from Safe Kids very moving
but it seemed that sponsor hadn't really
put in the time to figuring out how this
would be
implemented um and you know it seemed a
lot to put on the department of
safety um so I hope that he brings a
bill back and and does a lot of work to
see how he could implement this program
um in a better Bill next
year
anyone else wish to speak representative
Bale thank you Mr chair um I Echo that
this is a well-intentioned bill and I my
heart really goes out when you're living
in a community where there are frequent
drownings in the mar Mack River you know
you're you're really looking at what the
solutions can be um we heard some
testimony that was really compelling and
during that time I was I I found myself
thinking that there could be a
non-legislative
solution and I like um representative
lontine feel that it would be wonderful
if he could work on that and and um
bring it back this is an important bill
and there was a lot of heart that went
into it thank you anyone else wish to
speak to the motion representative Derby
thank you Mr
chair apparently um when people tell me
I don't talk enough I start talking
more oh my God what I
I um I would um I Echo what you know U
the last couple of speakers said but I
just want to mention that I think there
is um an appropriate place for the
sponsor to start engaging this is really
about injury prevention injury
prevention isn't um so much in the
department of safeties um you know uh
jurisdiction as it is the Department of
Health and Human Services and that's why
they actually um came and testified on
this bill there is a there is a council
though Council on resources and
development that coordinates across
agencies for these sort of cross cutting
purposes um one of the things that this
Council on resources and development is
responsible for is providing the
oversight relative to the Statewide
Public uh bow Access program very appoo
for uh for this measure especially where
um a lot of the recommendations for life
jackets would go so I would encourage
the sponsor to I will be vote in itl but
I would encourage the sponsor to you
know met uh talk speak with members of
the uh Department of Health and Human
Services Department of Safety have them
bring it up to the Council of resources
and development and see if they can
engage um not uh nonprofits in order to
uh to provide um this important measure
especially on the marac river which we
heard is one of the most dangerous in
the country thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion
saying no
one will clerk please call the
Rope yes on the motion of itl on House
Bill 1440 representative harb yes
representative Moffett yes
representative hgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative donelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative lit
yes representative Ryan yes and the
chair yes that's 20 to zero motion
passes
Z motion passes I
have
sent
okay now and the last one is House
Bill
1483 allowing subdivision regulations
concerning water
supply here recognizes representative
harb our motion yes Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion of interim study on HB
1483 is there a
second I second second by representative
bolia you wish to speak on your motion
yes thank you Mr chair uh I appreciate
the concern of this bill 1483 but in
testimony and reviewing the bill I felt
that uh perhaps this can already be
addressed by subdivision regulations and
I think it need needs a little more
study uh to see how can it be
implemented and it can it already be
implemented before we pass the Bill
thank you you wish to speak on your
second just briefly um yes I Echo uh
representative harb I think it's well
intentioned um after having served on
the planning board I can say that and
sitting through subdivision hearings
that people bring forward usually it's a
a giant engineering study that
accompanies a subdivision application
including these tests and um um I'm I'm
I'm hoping that um people will keep in
mind that we have a housing crisis here
and additional regulations are uh often
not uh conducive with impr making
improvements to our housing crisis so
thank
you good anyone anyone wish to speak to
the
motion repres representative
representative
rung thank you Mr chair um I'm going to
vote against the interm study um so that
an ought to pass motion can come
primarily because when I look at the
history of this issue we had a bill that
was brought up by a member of this
committee at the in 2019 representative
Hobson um and I believe representative
Mark Pearson was also involved in that
um because they had encountered a
subdivision in I believe it was in the
Kingston area that had um caused
neighboring dist uh neighboring homes to
have their Wells go dry and um and then
subsequent to that the sponsor of this
bill representative McGee had brought a
bill forth last year um it was if you
remember it was introduced by
representative
McWilliams that tried to uh approach
this issue as well um and the committee
ited that because it was going to
require a lot lot of extensive testing
hydrologist things like that and the
sponsor took back that feedback from
this committee to bring this forward and
this is really just enabling legislation
if you look at the first um on line
three it says requiring a water supply
study in accordance with local
regulations so it's allowing local
regulations to consider Water Resources
um as they're going through a pro
project approval process so I I think we
need to give our our planning boards and
our municipalities the um Power that
this bill provides them in looking at
Water Resources and how they may be
impacted with new subdivisions that
don't fall within the um large
groundwater withdrawals or other um
projects that would be under New
Hampshire Dees and and I do want to
remind the committee too that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association which
studies a lot of bills in depth did
support this bill so I'm I'm going to
vote against the itl so that a to pass
motion can be brought forward thank
you anyone else wish to speak
representative
Vale um the motion on the floor is
interm study point of clarification yes
okay so um all right I just want to Echo
what uh representative rung said we
looked at this bill last year there were
a lot of concerns that were brought
forward and this has returned with those
um
concerns excuse me last yes last year um
those concerns have been addressed as
far as what I can see um and so I just
really think enabling and not mandating
really comes forward for me with local
control and that we do want to enable
Town governments to have the ability to
oversee what's going on in their own
communities thank
you representative
Darby thank you Mr chair I'm sure I'm
going to take a lot of flak for this but
I'm gonna support your uh this notion of
interim study um I I think that the
sponsor did do a lot of work I think
that there is a real problem um the
sponsor talked about this um Coming
forth in their planning board you know
in their local planning board multiple
times um the New Hampshire Municipal
Association also supports
um there was this was previously studied
by um a subcommittee and um but that was
actually in 2010 and that's the reason
why I think it's reasonable to to
evaluate it again make sure that um
something
as potentially significant as um as you
know requiring a a hydrological survey
um and the impacts of that really gets
considered from all perspectives so
sorry to all the people that are gonna
uh throw Flack at me but I'm going to
support interim
study is there anyone else who wishes to
speak to the
motion if not clerk please call the
rooll thank you Mr chair on interim
study yep on interim study House Bill
1483 representative harp yes
representative Moffet yes representative
Horgan yes votes yes representative
Healey yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative dun yes
representative Vale no representative
rung no representative Kelly no
representative Simpson no representative
Baldwin
no representative Darby yes
representative ho
no Representative lontine no
representative lit no representative
Ryan no and the chair yes is 11 to9
motion passes 11 to
n
passes representative harb we would uh
write the the uh majority
yes and uh
there there will be there will be a
Minority Report thank you Mr chair let
me know who that
later uh that being said that I think we
are I would say uh CC but I don't think
anybody wants this
on this will be this will
be will they uh we'll start in uh couple
of seconds couple minutes let us as we
get our stuff
ready
the
conference you just you don't have to
come run it up you could you could just
you know thrown it on the floor
all
right let's get started on House
Bill uh
1494 relative to
ohvs rep representative Kelly the floor
is
yours thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for allowing me to speak today
on House Bill
1494 relative to ohvs um so to update
some of our newest members uh in 2022
this committee uh voted to create a uh
hb11 188 study committee on ohvs in New
Hampshire so this bill is uh born out of
some of the discussions that we've heard
in that uh committee the chairman and
myself are two members who serve on that
committee um the the I'm going to skip
there's five sections it's they're um
all related to hrvs but I'm going to
skip section one um right now and and
come back to that later so that study
commission was meant to be a place that
all discussions about ohvs could be had
um the numerous you know uh Rising
issues or concerns could be brought um
so we hear from a vast array of people
on the subject with a lot of different
um
motivations
um so section two of the bill that was
that I'm going to start by saying that
uh there I will be bringing forward an
amendment to this bill before we exec uh
execute um so I'll talk on touch on some
of those amendments that I've already
discussed with members who are going to
testify after me um but and and I'll
start by saying that section two is
going to be removed that was brought to
me by a local uh golf club um who
believed that the prohibition was in
state law and it turns out it's a
federal restriction um so we're just
going to go ahead and remove that uh
from the bill um section three uh it
takes language that already exists in
RSA 26182 in relation to other
agricultural vehicles um and then it
just extends that to utility vehicles um
many of you have probably seen stories
involving accidents with ohvs in the
southern half of the state where on the
road use of ohvs is less common a number
of these accident accidents involved uh
inappropriate use of special
registration plates uh there was a a
tragic one in Auburn in 2021 that
claimed the life of a mother and son
these special registrations exist to
help ease the regulatory burden on farms
and other small businesses it is vital
that we protect them um there's a myth
at at the same time there's a myth going
around that by simply registering a UTV
through a business you can drive it
anywhere um the commission has heard
that one contributing factor is the
inconsistent requirements between local
Town clerks um some will will ask for
more um evidence when when for creating
one of these registrations others will
not um and so it leads to this well I
just had mine registered in this town
and it was no problem they just checked
it off in other towns they people who
should deserve the license plate have to
jump through a couple Hoops um so this
is just taking language that's that's
already applied for other agricultural
license plates and then extends it to
the UTV license plate and it's meant to
help um shift the onus to the operator
to the person who is applying for the
permit to make sure they understand what
they're applying for and what the
license plate is meant to be be used
for and by doing this we can help um
protect that a industrial license plate
that is used by SM bus small businesses
and Farmers around our state um we can
help make sure that that is available to
them in the
future so section four of the bill um
this is a small fix to make sure that
funds are going to the appropriate place
so this deals with the ohrv event permit
that's issued by fishing game as anyone
on the ohrv commission would agree
there's a lot of confusion between this
fishing game permit and the special use
permit that's issued by dncr for events
on state lands so this is the fishing
game event permit and they are monitored
exclusively by fish and game with the
help of local law enforcement So
currently $15 of the $50 permit fee is
transmitted to dncr $7.50 goes to
Administration and $7.50 goes into the
grant and aid fund um and we're only
talking about a couple thousand each
year that gets transferred and we're
likely spending more splitting it up
into those funds than we are sending it
to the grant and aid fund uh so for
comparison the grant and aid fund budget
uh last year was $4 to5 million so we're
talking about 05% of those funds and
they probably could be better used by
fishing game to oversee the permits that
they are
issuing um this uh there's a correction
that will be issued in amendment to make
sure that this is apply to both
snowmobiles and ohvs this was meant to
be a b dealt with ohvs somehow it only
made it into the snowmobile portion of
the law so RSA 2155a applies to ohvs and
RSA 215 C applies to snow wheels so the
the language should be the same between
both um so section five of this bill um
is related to Grant aid funds and the
uses of them so one thing that I've
heard in the North Country um that's
been brought up to me by multiple people
is that the cost involved with
engineering larger projects can be
burdensome for
clubs uh so if a club is applying for
funds to let's say create a bridge um
you know they have to put up 50% of the
funds for that for that bridge they in
these larger project the things that
require more upfront costs they're
responsible for those entire upfront
costs because the department funds can
only be used in the 6 months after
they're issued so you know for something
like a bridge you could be spending
$50,000 on the bridge materials for the
club could be spending that getting
50,000 from um from the grant n program
but then they would have to put up you
know 35 $40,000 ahead of time for for a
larger project to make sure it's
engineered before they bring that
project to uh apply for the funds um so
the intent of that that was to ease that
burden on the clubs for these larger
projects um I think in light of you know
the in light of the the damage that
happened in December and the more we're
learning about the damage that's
happened in uh over over last summer the
I think it's I I I think I agree with
the people who are going to speak after
me that we should just hold off on
making that change but I think it's
something that should be discussed um
one of the arguments that going to be
made uh is going to be that these funds
have to be spent within six months from
the that sixth month requirement is
currently establishing rules not not
statute so I think it's completely
appropriate for if the legislature were
to allow them to be used for the funds
or direct dncr to allow them to be used
for these funds that they could be there
could be other rules created to make
sure that those engineering projects
aren't taking up all of the money for
for the projects that are shovel ready
um so that brings me to section one um
so section one is an attempt to get more
Buy in to the ohrv um program in our
state so U many of you and many people I
think in the southern part of the state
might think of Berlin as like we all
love ohvs and ohvs are the best thing
ever and we're going to keep supporting
them forever um I think you know living
in the community there is a um still a
very vocal group who think that ohvs
will go away and I think that that is
not a realistic belief I think that you
know we you know um that ohvs just like
snowmobiles are a um going to be a
fixture of New Hampshire for a long time
to come and I want them to be um so when
I hear those people and I do hear from
them uh enough um I I'm trying to think
of ways that we can make it so that they
can feel that they have some more
control over over the ohvs in our
state the the intent of this is to
expand the definition of an ohrv club uh
so it it eliminates the thing that says
that they have to be ohrv users and it
says I have to have a focus on ohrv so
that I just want to it does say it has
to have a focus on ohvs and maybe that
language could say it has to have the
primary focus bvs but I think that
there's an opportunity to to allow those
who see harm or feel harm uh with
ohrv to be able to deal with those
issues with the same state support that
we give to OHV users in the state um the
the by changing that definition we are
still requiring them to go through the
same application process so they would
still still have to show that they are
going to benefit the trail system in the
same way that these other projects are
going to benefit the trail system but
maybe there could be a state
organization who is you know listening
to those who feel the most affected by
ohvs and then addressing their concerns
I think that state our state departments
do an excellent job of of listening for
those type of complaints and responding
to them but they're not always equipped
to deal with them completely
um under current rules for the grant aid
program uh clubs are not the only ones
who can apply for funds uh towns um can
also apply for those funds currently but
yet no towns are applying for those
funds and I think that that shows that
there is a you know there are other
public you know it concerns that the
local municipality isn't equipped to
deal with or feels that they would
be harming their their other interests
by applying for those funds for certain
uses so I think that you know this is in
light of the damage in the Grant and a
funding that we're going to need over
the next year I I I also intend to
withdraw this part of the um bill um but
I did want to have that discussion I do
think that there is that there is more
that we can do as a state to address
some of those those concerns and maybe
make people feel like there's a bit
more that the state because the state
currently offers funding to ohvs to
incentivize them so you know if we can
have some way for the state to also give
those an opport give those who you know
who are traditionally opposed to ohrv
use an opportunity to use those funds
constructively towards the benefit of
ohrv use in our state I think it will
help the longevity of the program and
maybe lower some of the tensions that
we're uh that we feel uh in these
communities where Ohr use is more uh
common
um I'm happy to take questions
um thank
you any questions by members of the
committee representative run thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question um I'm a little
confused um when you me we're talking
about expanding the definition of ohrv
Club so that organizations that weren't
traditional like they don't
traditionally support ohrv use because
they have a focus on the use and so that
they could then get funds to improve
ohrv use I'm I'm kind of confused
because if there's a group that doesn't
support OVR ohrv use but they'd be
getting funds to improve the use of Ohr
if you could just kind of explain that
and then was that also a section you
said will come out an
amendment thank you yeah yes thank you
so sections one two and five I plan to
withdraw an amendment um so the yes the
the what I think we're going to hear is
that this will open up the program to
hundreds of other organizations to apply
for the f
I don't think I I Envision a existing
organization that could could use these
funds but for example when you open up a
trail on your property oh for example
let's just look at there is a currently
a connector Trail
between uh between north umberland and
colbrook and that trail is currently
closed to ohrv use due to landowner com
problems with the ohrv club who
represents that that trail so the the
landowner feels that the club is
not um addressing his concerns and I
know that um dncr has stepped in and
talked with this landowner before um but
that trail does remain
closed the I think that there could be a
third party group who could you know
address those concerns directly who
could you know listen to the land owner
you know he says that there's trash
problems on the property he says that
there's other concerns and specifically
address his concerns in a way that you
know a state organization may not be
equipped to do so um and and maybe you
know by you know addressing his concerns
directly um that we can continue that
trail connector being open so instead of
having to spend funds to build a new
trail that goes around his property we
can directly address his concerns and
get that property open um I think that
there's a lot of times where a trail is
on a private land owner's property on
the edge of a property and his abutters
have complaints about the use and they
have no control they feel they have no
control and oftentimes they don't have
any control over the use of on because
it's on another person's private
property so an organization that could
address those Butters
concerns could would benefit the clubs
the Trail's use because it's going to
keep it from being ch on other fronts um
and it's D dealing with them directly
and and quickly in a lot of
cases that example really helped explain
it thank you so much any other questions
representative
Bale yes um thank you uh for taking my
question and thank you Mr chair you
referred to the damage of last summer um
do you want to say more about what
happened last
summer
yeah so the the wash outs that we had
Statewide you know we've talked about
the I'm sure you've seen you know the
the uh money that had to go into the
highway budget all those highways you
know there's ohrv trails in all those
communities as well so many of them
exist along waterways and um other
corridors and they don't have the as
much uh existing you know Culvert
infrastructure and all those other
things so we're talking wash outs and
other issues there's currently Senate
Bill 397 that's working its way through
the Senate that's looking to add about
$2 million to the grant Aid budget um so
in light of those I don't think that
either of these um programs especially
because they don't take take effect
until next year would have a major
impact on the grant aid program but I
just don't I don't think there's any
reason to touch it this year I think
that we can we can deal with that in a
future um
session any other other questions by
representative
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Kelly for taking my
question this is there's a lot of pieces
to this bill I I have multiple questions
but I will just ask the one
initially um your section three you said
you know is the intent is to make sure
that people aren't I think you said
aren't misregistered their utility
vehicles but it seems to me the the
portion of Statute that you are updating
actually has a separate Roman 4 for
motorcycles trail bikes and agricultural
vehicles that meet ohrv and so I'm
wondering why you modified Roman 1
instead of Roman 4 where Roman 1 might
be like tractors and and have broader
implication broader impact than just
ohvs thank
you let me see if I can pull up 259
quickly and look at at it my so as I was
taking so I took the language from 2598
82 it's it's
26141 okay so so the 26182 or uh the the
was where I just took the language from
I had asked OS to just insert that into
okay the the under ohvs as well so it it
could have been misplaced
for well follow up thank you Mr chair
thank thank you again representative
Kelly um also um you know I I think I
got your gist of section four which is
you're you're saying hey that we're
we're chopping up this the fees that are
paid into little tiny pieces and fishing
game really needs the fees but I wonder
like it seems that some of the some of
the fees where this is going today are
to um Grant and kind funding for trail
maintenance um other Trail maintenance
and uh land purchases and easements and
will those you know are those will those
suffer will will um public lands will be
not able to sort of obtain the easements
that they need to make ohvs you know um
to expand ohrv use if if those funding
if that funding is
cut so the majority of funding is comes
from registrations so we're talking
about maybe
05% of funds
very very very small percent and the
fishing game could definitely use that
that fund those funds to to better
monitor to continue to monitor all the
permits that they um are they issue
under the event permit
program anyone else have a question
representative
lonte yes I was just trying to
understand the the section of um the
funds and how the fees and how these
were distributed I mean I think it seems
a little vague to just say there will
either go um to dncr or fishing
game
um are there and then but then you've
added the and um under rule
making um that you might impose
administrative fines and is that u a
potential source of funding could one go
to one and one to the other
I just think it was a little confusing
just by adding the or in
there yeah I'm a bit confused about
where that administrative findes section
came from uh my request to OS was to
Simply remove the section that says 750
shall go to and 750 shall go to and is
simply appropriate all to fishing game
um so that Miss must be in related to
you know some other um actually that's
in section five so that's that's
probably where that they came and again
I don't know why that appeared in there
because section five is was meant to
just add that stipulation to the Grand a
program Grant AG is currently only in
rules uh the rules or the the what it
can be applied to is only in rules so uh
it could be that they needed to add that
language to to make it so they could add
a statute to
that that doesn't answer your question
or does
uh maybe if
you you'll fix it you'll find the
reasons and fix that section five will
be completely removed so that part about
that will be removed and um I think that
uh both fishing game and dncr are
testifying you can ask them how what
percentage of funds are coming that way
the majority of funds four to5 million
are coming from other
sources any other questions by members
of the committee seeing none thank you
very
much chair recognizes Captain Mike Ean
from fishing
game good morning my name is Captain
Mike Leeman the hampsh fishing game
department I am the ohrv uh enforcement
safety and um training coordinator um
it's I want to thank representative
Kelly for bringing this bill uh it does
have a lot of well-intentioned things
from uh the 1188 commission um as far is
uh what I'm going to speak to today is
is really just number two and then uh
the section uh which was uh the event
permits
which find it
here so to the uh to start off uh this
went in front of uh Fishing Game
Commission and they were opposed uh to
um to the bill um for multitude of
reasons um one of which uh to speak to
number two which would be changing the
uh ATV um which um would add the uh age
of 14 and operating uh for a golf cart
and a golf facility um at this point
this only speaks to ATVs which um within
ohrv ATVs are more of your four-wheel
Ride On Top motorcycle style um
machine whereas a golf cart would not be
an ohrv it's not considered an ohrv um
so this really uh would not uh sit
within that um and we wouldn't want any
confusion between a UTV which is more of
your dune buggy uh with steering wheel
which would be more of the look more
like a golf cart and get that confused
with the two um and there is no age
limit within those um from our
impression uh this is more of an issue
with the golf club and not an ohrv issue
so that was really why we were opposed
to that section as far as event permits
um we have no issue with the changes um
within uh
215c um but it only speaks to 215c which
is snowmobiles um there is another
section within 215 a30 which speaks to
events um within o the ohb statute so um
that would have to be added um the
reason in uh behind the changes to uh
215c uh for the event permits um was and
and really speaking to the changes in
the breakdown of the um fee for the
permit uh really what that comes from is
um and the reasoning behind it is that
the addition to this would be that we
would keep a public calendar um which we
certainly can do through our public
affairs and um in the review of of uh
all those event permits
um but really um the event permits the
majority of them do not occur on Trails
some do uh this event permit only speaks
to unregistered snow machines or o hrvs
uh for which uh the fishing game
department would would enforce um so
really for the $50 with the only $750
cents coming to fishing game uh we would
uh we would be doing the the work and
enforcing it so we would process the the
permit um notify make sure that
everything is legitimate on that permit
there is we have had circumstances where
people enter things and say yes I spoke
to the town and the police department
and none of that is true so we have to
verify all of that we have to notify the
officers supervisors for that area so it
takes us time um there's a lot of leg
work there and then if there is a
problem within the event permit we have
to send an officer to basically enforce
that portion of our loss so um we feel
that the $50 and and that there is not a
desire to increase that fee um from $50
uh so that there can be a breakup of
distribution and where there isn't a
whole the majority of these permits
aren't occurring on trails that the the
bulk of the work is being done by
fishing game and that's why that change
would the $50 would come to fishing game
and not have a breakup and Grant need
and um that would not take away from
what comes out of
registrations um for the grant n program
so and I won't speak to the grant n
program or any other section because I
think there are others from other
agencies that are more qualified to that
so um that's really the sections that I
want to speak on
okay any questions
Captain representative har
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question just
very briefly you said that it only
covered 215c because uh and that's
snowmobiles what was the other chapter
what was the other section you mentioned
so the other section that would affect
ohvs is 25
a30 okay anyone else for
questions seeing none very much thank
you Greg
renie Hampshire Trails
Bureau good morning uh my name is Craig
rany I'm the chief of the Bureau of
trails at the Department of Natural and
cultural resources and I just handed out
some written testimony regarding the
bill um we're not taking a position on
it we just wanted to share a few
concerns with it and some of the
language um as representative Kelly had
already mentioned
um so the redefining the term ohrv Club
um to remove that the requirement of the
club being a group of ohrv users to the
club um only having a focus on ohrv use
um you know the O ohrv users help fund
the grant and aid program as you heard
through the ohrv registrations so
therefore the definition of ohrv Club
should continue to be members who are
actual ohrv you know users as this model
has worked well New Hampshire for over
50 years um you know as representative
Kelly mentioned the the the commission
the fiveyear study committee to study
ohrv use in New Hampshire you know we've
been meeting since 2022 it's an active
group um you know it's a full fiveyear
study and and we would recommend you
know allowing that study committee to
continue its research on some of these
issues and make their recommendations as
a full committee prior to making any
statutory changes on
that um but but as representative Kelly
said that's section one of the proposed
language he is withdrawing so that uh
may not be a concern any longer um the
other section um in section five that we
were concerned about is the distribution
of grant and aid reimbursements for up
to 50% engineering costs as
representative Kelly mentioned uh most
Trail related G projects that we fund
they don't require engineering study uh
most of their projects are considered di
Minimus or maintenance projects um for
just ongoing maintenance and
improvements um and again even most of
the projects qualify for simple Trail
notification through de which is a
really simple permit process there's no
engineering involved with that uh so
again it's very rare that we have
engineering cost involved with Trail
maintenance projects and the you know
the 100 snowmobile clubs and the 25 ATV
clubs in the state that that help with
Trail maintenance again the majority of
it is just Trail ongoing Trail
maintenance for snowm bills it's winter
grooming as well that the grant aid
helps to reimburse but it's it's a
regular maintenance um program um so the
the concern about putting money into
engineering um firms and groups to to
study or engineer on different projects
I don't see it as um something that
occurs that often in the program U but
the concern could be that if monies were
redirected to engineering firms or
Consultants um that less of the
maintenance regular ongoing maintenance
of the trail system would would take hit
from those monies not being put into
direct maintenance and it could affect
Public Safety of Trail
users um but again that section 52 I
think representative Kelly mentioned um
withdrawing that uh section with
engineering so again the testimoni
really was based on those two sections
as the main concern um but I hopefully
the committee will continue to meet uh
chairman is on that as well and and
we'll uh come up with more suggestions
in the future as we conclude that again
another uh three plus years of of
meetings to talk about it I think our
next meeting is coming up in March so um
happy to answer any
questions any
questions by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Richard
Parsons uh New Hampshire Highway Vehicle
Association
good morning chairman Rulo and members
of the committee my name is Rich Parsons
I work at ryp grite strategies here in
conquer and um I'm here today on behalf
of New Hampshire off highway vehicle
association uh we were opposed to the
bill as introduced uh we had some
productive conversations with
representative Kelly and we understand
um he's going to be removing section one
and two and five and I think with that
we're fairly neutral on the other
section changes I'll just say in terms
of you know the sworn Avid David piece
to get back to your question earlier we
have that language already in statute
for special commercial plates which have
the ability to um access the main roads
for special purposes and the Agriculture
and Industrial plates have the ability
depending on which use it is to go up to
10 Mi you know between the farmland and
2 miles I think if it's an industrial
complex land
and putting that in there will will
ensure that you know when a town clerk
gets a request for one of them they have
to sign that they understand they can't
use it to go to Dunkin Donuts they can't
use it to go grocery shopping that it
has to be for the uh Agriculture and
Industrial use there's enforcement of
this section is all over the place um
you know some clerks don't give almost
any of these um kind of plates out and
some just give it to anyone it doesn't
really matter the vehicle so um we
definitely do not have a a problem with
including that in in the Agriculture and
Industrial section and we think it's in
the the proper section there um in terms
of the event permits piece we also um I
think agree that you know it's currently
in the snowmobile section and if this is
geared at ohvs it should be in ohrv
section as well or um and if the
snowmobilers are um okay with it in
their section but I think they'll speak
to that a little later
um I think in the event permits um the
1188 study commission which thank you to
representative Kelly and representative
Rula for being a part of and the late um
Suzanne Smith for forming the committee
I think you know it's very important
that it's a five-year Commission because
a lot of these issues are very complex
and take a lot of time I mean the event
permits we've created diagrams to try
and uh differentiate all the different
um event permits there are between dncr
you know do Crossing permits um fishing
games so while this I think uh moves the
money with fishing game and and creates
some improvement we hope that this
commission continues to work on the
event permit section because we do think
that there is some additional Clarity
and you know a more comprehensive um
look at them in general that needs to
continue to be done um I will um just
going back to what representative Kelly
said in terms of um working with land
owners and and while there are some
issues with land owners I think our
clubs work very closely with land owners
and municipalities um to make sure that
everyone is happy I mean 80% or so of
our trail system relies on private land
owners we have some clubs that to get
approval for projects they need over 170
signatures of land owners to be able to
get permission to to do some of this
stuff so I think we work very well with
many um land owners to the state there
are obviously situations where we don't
um and we are concerned about opening
the definition of OHV clubs um from this
dedicated money for um from ohrv
registrations for ohrv Riders and users
to to help with that if if a group that
maybe isn't getting along with the
landowner like the example given if a
third party group all of a c sudden
exists and there's almost like a
duplicative efforts trying to be done
maybe to to fix one certain trail system
and who does dncr work with who does the
town work with um I know it was
mentioned that municipalities don't
necessarily apply for G funds but in
many cases they are very closely um
partnered with clubs you know sometimes
they identify issues for clubs that they
want fixed or they hear from land owners
that they want addressed and so the
clubs are the ones that take it on and
fix it as as you know class six roads
Town cannot maintain class six roads so
a lot of um circumstances it would you
know the clubs are the ones that apply
because they're the ones that can
provide the matching funds because the
municipality cannot be the one to do it
on those roads um so I I I guess while
municipalities maybe have not been
applying much for Gia they are closely
um working with folks so all that to say
you know section one and section five
looking to change the Gia funds we
appreciate um the sponsor's willingness
to um continue to work on that at the
study commission level and I think have
these conversations which I think are
important conversations to continue to
have and also that uh the recognition
that all the storm damage that was
caused last year caused millions of
dollars in damage to the trail system
between the July storm alone which you
know there's a bill in trying to get $2
million that's in Senate Finance um a
million of which would just be for State
Trails um itself and damage that
occurred and that's just the July storm
that doesn't include the December storm
so Gia funds are really going to be
utilized these next couple of years to
to Really it usually is to maintain
these Trails but I think it's a lot of
it's going to unfortunately have to be
used to to help repair and fix them so
we appreciate his willingness to hold
off on that and continue those
discussions um and with that I think
I'll I'll take any questions any
questions from members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you and final
card Brian
L representing the New Hampshire
Snowmobile
Association
good morning chairman renzou and members
of the House committee my name is Brian
L and I serve as the vice president of
the New Hampshire Snowmobile Association
I do have a a brief prepared statement
here to share with you on behalf of the
association uh regarding the language
for House Bill
1494 uh the association isn't in
opposition to the language change simply
because grant and aid was specifically
designed to help and support clubs with
Trail grooming and maintenance costs the
grant nid program is funded by
snowmobile
andv registrations and you can imagine
those registrations are down
significantly with non-conducive with
winter weather
conditions uh I'm not sure if any of you
have been on the receiving end of an
engineering bill before but I can assure
you if you have how expensive they can
be and quickly spiral out of spiral out
of control the grant nade system simply
can't afford to pay any portion of any
engineering bills it just wasn't
designed to do so at this
point further if this change were to
take place
it could be misinterpreted as a deao
prerequisite for building recreational
buges Bridges culverts and Etc on our
trails and could completely drain the
Gia Fund in the future until Gia becomes
substantially more robust these types of
additional draws cannot be implemented
without
consequence um I believe the
representative is going to withdraw this
section five so this is at this point
most likely a moot point but I just
wanted to state that on behalf of the
association to the committee uh thank
you for your time and with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions you may
have any any questions by members of the
committee representative
M thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr lb
for coming to our committee today good
to see you good to see you um question
for you so if one two and five are
out does the association still object to
then parts of section four if I
understand you correctly the the fee
distribution and whatnot so I believe
the association positions on the balance
of the bill would be like
neutral so I don't think we're we're
we're not concerned with that further
question for a
followup so so section four
then if if it's if section four stays in
you're you're fine with
the the uh the division between 215c and
2155a snowmobiles and
ohvs I think we would be Tim okay
is that it
thanks is there anyone else from the
committee thank you very much I think I
had all the pink
cards there anybody else who is looking
to speak if
not I will close the hearing thank you
very
much and we're back at
one
he's on the committee with you you
haven't finished he's coming in with
this knock three
sections yeah I would talk to him
because it's like he's going against his
own
commission representative Kelly can I
speak with you for a few
minutes
fire burning well I got a million two
deal going and then they changed the
deal at the last minute so they're
they're all waiting for me to call
try to fix it gotta it's only a
million your
way
e
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Erica Leon I represent the town
of dairy and I'm here to introduce my
bill House Bill 153 relative to the
definition of wetlands I live on sheno
road um potent potentially better known
as the end of the new exit 4A um there's
a lot of different work that's going on
and driving home I found it really
interesting that there were the little
pink flags for Wetlands everywhere on
the uphill side of the road just about
everybody along the road has small
little puddle sized Wetlands designated
on their property and that's why I
brought this bill to me a wetland is
actually a viable ecosystem that
actually can support plants and life in
more than just a small little area
that's smaller than this table um as I
work through this um I do have to admit
that I had my attention on some other
bills so I probably should have done a
little bit more homework on this in
order to better look into the whole
process um but I do believe that it's
very important that we are not
designating puddles as Wetlands um I did
look back on the history of some of my
property and there's a very large
vibrant ecosystem that was created when
chenita Road was put in instead of the
old 192 Highway it ended up blocking off
the flow and now there's beavers there's
birds there's fish living along the edge
of my property so by designating that a
wetland that's created only by the
failure of a state federal orun IAL
Public Works project probably would have
pointed to that vibrant ecosystem and
that wasn't my intention my intention is
that if you change the Contours of the
road or a culvert underneath the road
gets clogged and suddenly you have water
backing up that's not really a true
viable Wetland and we should be focusing
our resources on those good areas um I'm
actually on the committee to study um
environmentally triggered um illnesses
and we were talking about
cyanobacteria and that ALS also seems
I'm trying to get more information from
Dees but it seems that when there's an
inappropriate flow of water either too
fast or too slow there's more of a
chance I'm trying to get uh it seems
like there may be more of a chance that
you get the cyanobacteria because it's
not a healthy flowing situation of the
water where it should be traversing it
should be filtering as it's going
through um as it's going through the
natural process of water moving along so
I I am concerned that if we end up
designating a lot of these puddles as
Wetlands we have other problems between
mosquitoes um and just just harboring
other things that we don't want but I
didn't write this correctly um what I
would ask you to do would be to interim
study this bill because I think that
there is a true need to make sure that
our exemptions are correct but I didn't
do it the right way in this bill so I
hope that you could humor me by doing
that I'd love to work with you over the
summer to figure out how to make sure
that we do give the exemptions summer or
fall uh but that we do give their
correct exemptions to make sure that
we're not calling things Wetlands that
really shouldn't be um while we can we
can focus our resources and not take
people's land um and and take the use of
their land just because they have a
puddle that um has fostered a few seeds
and has developed what technically
counts as a wetland so with that I'd be
happy to take any questions any
questions members of the committee
representative
Bale thank you Mr chair um thank you U
representative Lyon for presenting the
bill and um for taking my question um
you mentioned that you live um near exit
4A is that i93 um yes so it' be exit 4A
off of i93 thank
you it's not built yet no the they're so
they're still constructing the highway
over the freeway but I'm right at the
end of the two miles so on Cheno Road
they've been flagging all of that in
order to do their survey work I think
they're at 30% design completion right
now representative run thank you Mr
chair and thank you repes representative
for taking my question um you know I
first joined this Committee in 2018 2019
and we have we get a lot of wetlands
bills and I was and it's the statute's
very comprehensive very detailed and I
was just wondering um did you meet with
people from Dees from the wetlands
Bureau when you drafted this this bill
uh no I didn't unfortunately we had some
losses in my family so I wasn't as
diligent in preparing this as I
otherwise would have been because I'd be
of the mind that perhaps instead of the
committee committing time over the
summer on this maybe if you just met
with Dees and got their feedback on it
um it just it's just an idea thank
you anyone else representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question definitely I'm interested in
understanding impacts you know where it
may not look like areas or Wetlands um
so the you know the statute talks about
P pervasive um vegetation in saturated
soil can you can you describe a bit more
that you know when you mention you're
driving up the road and you see a lot of
areas marked off as um with pink flags
which are marked as Wetlands can you
describe a little bit more the
characteristics of that area um thank
you it is um essentially sort of the
unimproved road shoulder where you have
somebody's property that ends up dipping
down a little bit before it goes over
the hill um sometimes that is the area
that tends to naturally drain to
whatever draining place there is but
because there's been an uneven
distribution of it you have something
that would be a bit of a stream bed but
there's low points and then those low
points within there because some seeds
were able to germinate as you as you
have the silt and everything else wash
off you get to have good nutrients in
those locations as well so you have
small areas maybe this big that have
some of those Wetlands type plants but
it's simply because in the process of
flowing to an area of drainage there was
enough time for for it to sit and dwell
so that you'd get a few plants but it's
right on the roads side it's one where
there's not it's not a good location for
any animals at all um and it's simply
just sort of a failure of drainage we
have quite a few coverts that have it
seems that they've collapsed underneath
our road um I spoke to people in other
areas where um their towns continually
sand their roads as opposed to plowing
them and they built up over time so that
what used to be able to flow in certain
areas can't just because of that
man-made distribution of materials so I
my thought is to make sure that we can
have a good way to deal with those areas
that that really that really aren't a
vibrant and healthy Wetlands but just
happen to be saturated and happen to
have caught and fostered some seeds um
and make sure that we're not just incre
that we're not focusing our resources in
the wrong
way anyone
else seeing no
one thank you very much thank you and
I'm going to go back over to my
committee to exact so thank you very
much call uh barene forest from New
Hampshire
Dees good afternoon my name is darling
Forest the current Welton buau
administrator at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services I
believe the department emailed a copy of
its letter of testimony to folks
yesterday um which hopefully you all
have today since I've just realized I
have 40 copies of my letter of testimony
for the Department for House Bill 1554
which is
next um to summarize to summarize that
letter and since I figured you they
always give me a they always pass
something around so my apologies I'm uh
well prepared for the next hearing
so the department uh is opposed to the
legislation is crafted
um I'm uh on behalf of the department it
is good to hear that representative Lon
has suggested uh possibly study so that
we have time to work with her uh to
determine what her concerns are our
concerns with this legislation is that
the definition of
wetland is an understood scientific
definition it is a commonly
defined land form there is a uniform
definition that's used primarily
Nationwide please understand that while
some folks May argue who's got
jurisdiction over one Wetland what
wetlands in different states and all of
that what is a wetland is not normally
the argument that is a very consistent
definition to say that something is a
wetland unless it's caused caused by a
certain matter or a certain situation it
is still wet it is still that thing if
we have a situation where we're arguing
causality what that will do is create a
lot of just arguments is there an
advantage to arguing cause or not um do
you need a permit or not how much of
that Wetland is caused because of the
roadway and how much of that Wetland was
not and we spend a great deal of time
arguing over essentially
um what's going to come down to whether
or not a permit is needed it doesn't
change the way it functions in the world
it doesn't change whether it is habitat
or not it doesn't change whether it
provides flood storage or nutrient
attenuation or contaminant attenuation
it still does those things the only
difference in changing the definition
would be determining whether or not it
falls under our
jurisdiction on whether or not you need
a permit so the effective way to do that
isn't to change the definition if if the
legislature ever determined there's a
need for something to not need a
permit then call it what it is but
simply say this activity or this thing
doesn't need a permit so the way the
methodology for this bill was our
primary concern it was it seemed
technically
flawed um and in doing in developing
that analysis we did have to presume
somewhat what representative lon's
intent was it sounds like we may have
presumed a little bit wrong we look
forward as I said earlier to to working
with her um in the
future so that's that's the
general position of the department
um this is just not it's a it's going
to it's going to provide an additional
reason to argue about something with
very little beneficial outcome at the
end so we would prefer if this goes
forward if if that is an intent a
different
method I'll ask myself a question
first uh there are certain exceptions
that to the wetlands uh I think Farm
ponds if I'm not mistaken are exe ex
except Exempted from uh uh some of the
regulations around that there are
exemptions of my am I correct there are
many there are exemptions by Statute and
exemptions by rule as well okay uh maybe
if you could go over a little bit more
what they might be uh so as an example
so exemptions usually focus on
activities so the cleaning of culverts
is Exempted the maintenance of farm
ponds storm water ponds fire
ponds water conveyance systems all of
those things are Exempted from permits
certain types of Maintenance of seaw
walls are Exempted from the the need for
a
permit there are um exemption by rule we
have exemptions that require simple
notification for geotechnical borings
for um emergencies for oil remediation
activities if there's something where
for instance you have an oil spill we
don't want you getting a wetland permit
before you go in and clean it up if
you're um anytime you're working under
their directive I would direct you to if
you want to read the whole list the
world's longest uncomfortable sentence
it is RSA
42a colon
3 I believe it's Roman numeral 4 A B and
C are specifically exemptions within the
law and as a follow on to that uh is
there is
this
issue around uh encroaching Wetlands
where or developing
Wetlands where Wetlands uh where you
have not no wetlands and then water
maybe drainage starts a wetland at what
point can you say stop the Wetland and
return it to what it was originally so
if you have an if you have an area
understand that there are three criteria
under the definition to delineate a
wetland one of those is soil chemistry
you need to have the hydrology present
and it has to be present long enough to
affect the soil chemistry which will
then affect the type of plants that can
grow there it takes a few years before
soil chemistry actually shows physical
changes that you would need to delineate
something out as a jurisdictional
wetland so at any any point in those
years to correct that you you should um
if you have a situation where for
instance culverts need to be resized or
culverts
collapsed if you maintain that CT and
now you allow proper passage of water
then that water isn't building up there
so that chemistry even if it has begun
to show hydr
characteristics will then begin to
revert back to its its normal more
oxidized physical characteristics in
chemistry and won't come back as as a
wetland soil so timing varies on a
number of things mostly associated with
soil chemistry and plant
responsiveness but it usually takes
years before something actually
changes thank you representative Darby
you have a question thank you Mr chair
so what um
what does
the taking representative lons um
scenario where there's some work going
on and they they need to Mark the
wetlands on the side what impact is that
going to have to say the construction on
that road where let's say there's a
drainage ditch and some areas have had
depressions for years as you mentioned
and so there's so what what's the goal
of of treating those as
wetlands
so in treating those as Wetland it
depends on whether or not it's an
existing highway or you're maintaining a
new
highway when you have Roadside ditches
or roadside depressions that are
collecting water the questions there are
several um questions that would come up
such
as is this you have nutrient attenuation
a lot of our roads because they're
historic they don't have um storm Water
Management they weren't built at a time
when storm water management was
something that was considered all of
that road salt all of the stuff that's
getting washed off your car or falling
off your vehicle that is going into
those roadside Wetlands which then those
chemicals are broken down and attenuated
in those roadside Wetlands those
roadside Wetlands serve as flood
storage for all of that runoff if it's
not going to a detention Basin that
gives where you have the impervious
surface which isn't just the pavement
you need to compact your road base so
that your road base is solid those
compacted soils and the pavement itself
is not taking in water anymore it won't
let water infiltrate so you need those
adjacent Wetlands to give that water a
chance to infiltrate back into a
groundwater system and be treated as it
does so so it's filtering out some of
the chemicals and the nutrients they do
provide some some habitat value which is
kind of a catch22 will be the first to
admit it because on one hand you want
that habitat on the other hand you don't
want it on the road
because the the animals don't seem to do
very well out
there so it it does provide a certain
amount of habitat some of the most
valuable habitat we have in New
Hampshire that is always at risk is
vernal pools which are a simple
ephemeral pool they tend to show up in
the spring
that are key habitat types
for uh certain reptile and amphibian
species that are the start of the food
chain those are hard to
recreate but strangely as much as
they're difficult to recreate on
purpose they tend to just accidentally
happen in logging roads and roadside
depressions in part because there is no
one going out there because you're in
the roadway rideway or nearby it's
someplace that doesn't get the
activity uh and it tends to get good
light so you have the shrubby growth
that you might need for some of these
these Critters to use as cover in that
habitat so there's there's any number of
things and values that these roadside
habitats or any other incidental
habitats can use one of the things that
uh we are looking at moving forward we
at Dees um are starting within for those
who didn't know the New Hampshire GE
geological section is embedded at Dees
they are embarking on a study to assist
towns with planning for asset by asset I
mean Culvert
replacement where on one hand everybody
thinks it's a good idea to upssize your
Culvert so they pass water better you
want to pass that water quickly on the
other hand sometimes by downsizing a
culvert you hold water back and what
that does is it slows down the
progression of a flood through it
creates flood storage higher in the
Watershed so you know some of these
projects some of these older road
projects is in fact a can provide a
mechanism by which to create flood
storage control and capacity and that is
something that we will be working with
um to develop tools for the town to help
them integrate that as part of their
flood resiliency Pro uh planning and
programming moving forward so that's
probably one of the most overlooked
aspects of these areas is just flood
storage if that water is ponded there
then it's not in the Stream and it's not
contributing to the flood it's it's that
retention is
important any other questions
representative
Bale thank you Mr chair and thank you
for um taking my question so I'm
thinking about this little area um in
NASA where there's a Circ
circumferential Highway at the south end
and where they have built the road up
around it there is a natural depression
and there's quite a vibrant little
Wildlife um biome going on there because
there's a wetland that was created so
this is something that we would want
isn't
it that Wetland May well have been
created with intent when the road was
built as a precisely for for the flood
storage and infiltration purpose purp
that is a when we work with DOT as part
of their roadway design that is
something that we actively ask them to
work in is areas for collection of storm
water and infiltration and treatment so
yes any other
questions seeing
none thank you very
much
Kimberly peace peace peace peace to you
too peace be
upon thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee for hearing us
today my name is Kimberly peace I am the
chair of the legislative committee for
the New Hampshire Association of natural
resource scientists we go by the
shorthand of nanners and new Hamp and
nanners is the um sorry let me get my
notes straight A Statewide nonprofit
Professional Organization whose
membership includes Wetland scientists
soil scientists and Wildlife biologists
from the professional Consulting
Community from the state's academic and
public sectors there are over 300
practicing certified we and scientists
in New Hampshire and we serve as
Liaisons between developers and local
state and federal government officials
and we assist in balancing wise growth
and development Environmental Protection
and the rights of private property
owners and we assist them with our
technical expertise founded on
scientific principles so the I the group
that I'm here to speak with they are the
people who would take go out in the
field and um as representative Leighton
said um Place those pink flags and
identify the wetlands we call it Wetland
delineation where's the Wetland and
where's the Upland and where's the line
in between those those resources and
we're here to comment on this bill
because we um as uh Miss Force said so
eloquently uh a wetland is a resource it
is a land form and it is a
well-established resource that is
defined by soils hydrology and presence
of vegetation and so because that
definition is so well-versed um
Nationwide it there's there's no um
rationale behind what caused the Wetland
or how it Formed it simply is or is not
a wetland and and the identification of
a wetland is different as she spoke on
to the jurisdiction of a wetland so
there are wetlands and then there is
jurisdiction over whether or not you
need a permit or how or if you can
develop that Wetland or do certain
activities in or around those Wetlands
but none of that speaks to the
definition of wetlands and while um
culverts are a challenge in situations
where they become blocked um they can
create a wetland that can be valuable or
they can be a challenge and there are
certain situations you know can be
looked at from good or bad um but the
the fact that whether it's a wetland or
not is just simply based on those three
parameters so we uh understand that
there are concerns that there are
wetlands within the state that may seem
low functioning or may seem um to have
popped up sort of for um man-made
reasons the fact is that those um
situations can be dealt with either
through legislative um through rul
making or through guidance or exemptions
and there are currently lots of
exemptions available to um clean out
culs or to unblock culverts um as needed
and as as as is um in a way that gets
looked at in a positive way so that that
the whole situation gets looked at
before um before the certified Wetland
scientist has to stand in the field and
say is this a resource or is it not and
and what is its cause that that second
step is just not part of that
delineation process and we feel strongly
that that would be um sort of mixing up
the process of identifying what a
wetland is in the field versus how you
deal with the jurisdiction and
permitting that might come from that um
the potential alteration or impacts to
those Wetlands so we just wanted to send
uh myself to today to hear what was said
here today in the committee into here
representative Leighton um you know and
as she pointed out there have been
Wetlands that have been created that and
per this rule change could even be um
considered not a wetland and that's
that's not not really the case in hand
the case is um really what we tend to do
or what we want to do as a state with
Wetlands where there could be blocked
culs or cul issues which could be
changed or not and it and it really I
think the whole picture has to be looked
at and I don't think that the solution
is by changing the definition of
wetland any questions by members of the
committee seeing no one oh
thank you Mr can you just um tell me uh
the name of your organization again sure
it is the New Hampshire Association of
natural resource scientists thank
you that
it thank you thank you very
much have no more pink
cards uh any else one else uh want to
have a speak on this or have a uh we me
let me ask take Now personal privilege
on this as a chair
uh there is a you you heard
representative uh Leon ask
about uh you know having this be
a a interim
study maybe I should ask representative
Force representative for I just I just
demoted you I'm sorry
I and not only that not only that I just
gave you a hell of a demotion in your
[Laughter]
paycheck just as an as an I would like
your opinion would having uh this this
committee spend time working on that uh
on the on the uh on this issue or would
you rather have uh representative
Leighton spend time with you working on
the
issue for us as Department I don't know
that it please don't be offended I don't
know that it matters much if you have a
formal committee or or not if there's
any group of legislators who wants to
work with
us we're not going to say
no no what I'm talking about being being
just being effective knowing how INE
effective we can be at
times
so it's up to it's up to the comme
whether
keep you have that structure and you
feel provit to you as a
committee
dep you know even if members of
comme you're good you're good I got got
got to admit it it's like it's like
playing hockey and you should did it
again yes yes
representative turn on your like turn on
the light and exec this bill and I'm GNA
move to
it uh not not be uh now I don't if I can
do that not this is actually right now
this is a uh to executive now would be a
uh decision of myself and repres
representative Bale and it would have to
be a unan a decision unanimous between
the two and my policy is I would never
exec a
bill and itl it the first day okay uh
give it give give it time if it's if
it's if we're all in agreement that it's
good and and the person is here yeah why
not you know if it's not I don't want to
have people leave
up you're correct that that is would be
very impolite yes to do that thank you
sir I withdraw that uh I've seen no
other
uh no other bu
comments Dam
I that hand's getting quicker I'll tell
you that's
the
yeah
that's right that's
right I just want to say I'm I would not
be in favor of uh executing this bill
right now at all okay thank you all
right being seeing no more more
business close the hearing and uh we got
till to two o' I guess I'll write other
report
yeah
yeah I
know so we we'll see
yeah
and house bill
1542 representative
Coker the floor is
yours thank you very much Mr chairman um
so House Bill 1542 is a pretty simple
bill um basically it allows you to have
a photographic copy of your Boer Safety
license so um the the Genesis of this
came I'm part of a boat club and we all
use different boats and uh somebody was
saying how it it stinks that they can't
just have the uh their boter certificate
on their phone and be able to show a
copy if the Marine Patrol pulls you over
so technically you're supposed to have
that on you um if it's if you're
operating a a vehicle over 25 horsepower
so basically this law would allow you to
just put it get a copy of it on your
phone and um that would be it that would
just satisfy that law um I have an
amendment to this because I C talk to a
captain dunlevy and basically he said
that there's a barcode on the back
that's very important so it would be the
front and the back and I tried to get
that printed out but I was uh I don't
have power at my house because they're
putting in fiber optic cabl so as I was
running out the door I was like now
there goes my plan so I I put in a
request to get it printed but it should
be ready to
go so that's about it it's pretty simple
okay
question thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Koker for taking my
question so I just wanted to ascertain
now this is a certificate that you
physically carry but you also have a
digital copy on your
phone so so what this would do is that
you wouldn't have to you wouldn't have
to physically carry it anymore you just
have a c you could have a copy on your
phone and that would would satisfy the
law because right now a lot of people
don't actually have it on them and they
have 48 hours to to provide the
information to the Marine Patrol
so representative R thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I'm
reading the bill representative Coker
and I'm it seems pretty clear that it
says the certificate shall be a physical
original or copy or an electronic copy
or a photograph of the certificate on
electronic device
so I mean does that already kind of
imply that is both sides and by the way
I actually have mine so if anybody wants
to see it that's what it looks like um
can I see one I don't I don't have a
boat as a person without a boat but I I
you know it is boatless I mean it is a
good idea because most people keep like
I pulled it out of my wallet but I'm not
going to take my wallet on the boat
because my luck it would fall over so
but the way I'm reading the bill
though and maybe this will be a good
question for Captain dun love but it it
appears to me if you're going to have a
copy of it it would be both
sides yeah I mean I just wanted to just
for for the Marine Patrol because I
he'll be able to testify a little bit
more to to the convenience of it but I
just wanted it to be clear for people it
is the front and back I just want to
make that 100% clear okay thank
you just just in looking at that it
appeared to be more than a UPC it was it
looked like to be the computer thing a
barcode yeah yeah reader that it reads
same thing that you have on a TV screen
if you want to buy
something
yeah oh okay hey we got two all right
none of you guys are going to be able to
have your
Bo it's coming back to you it's coming
back it's coming
back yes sir
all right is and that's and that's
that's the amendment that's that that
I've already had made up I just I I did
not I didn't even think about my power
being out when I went to go print it and
then I so I requested a print but it
hasn't been enough filled yet so okay uh
is there any other questions
representative Donnelly then
representative Darby the
D's thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question so I have a boat and
actually what's funny is my license is
actually shrink wrapped with my boat
right now uh cuz I don't ever take it
out of the boat I leave it with the boat
how often do you just a question for you
how often do you switch um vessels I
switch boats all the time because I we
we we have a boat club so we we tend to
just take whatever boat's available and
then normally we go to my buddy's Dock
and then he has jet skis so we go off
and do that so I am constantly on and
off of different boats U personally and
it was one of those things that just got
brought up and a bunch of people are
like yeah that would be that would be
awesome so it's just I think it's just
it's it's an easy convenience and if it
doesn't inconvenience the Marine Patrol
and doesn't make a difference I think
there's no reason why not to to do
it representative Derby but you add next
and then repres
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question so um I
totally makees sense to me I just want
to say like this does allow for a copy
and we're talking about water and I
could imagine that somebody has a paper
copy right and and it gets wet and now
you can't read the bird code anymore so
you might think about if you're me
amending it anyway to have like a
legible copy especially since that
barcode is very important yeah I'm I'm
open to whatever friendly amendments the
committee wants to uh put on to it I
mean the the thing is one thing to think
about is that already a lot of people
just don't carry it on them a lot of
people I've talked about this with are
like oh I have to carry that I didn't
realize I have to carry that so um
that's one thing to think about is it's
better to have something other than
nothing I mean there is an electronic
copy in your
build what was that did you talk were
you just saying electronic copy well
this the first Clause is a physical Co
original or copy and so that copy to me
means to me a paper copy copy and could
be like a photoc copy and I'm just
thinking I could imagine making a bunch
of these copies and putting them like
any place you might need them but then
they might get wet and so it's if they
really need to scan the thing and it's
wet it's not going to be scanned so
that's why I was just thinking it could
you might want to clarify that the um
certific the label has the um barcode
has to be legible has to be legible
okay representative wolf thank you Mr
chairman um a question directed to the
chairman um is this something that
should go through legislation or should
it be um done through rules in case
something happens down the road that it
becomes I can Envision a you know a
magnetic thing on the side of a boat or
something like
that
uh well you can't do rules without
legislation but uh you can do
legislation without rules okay I think
you need the rules I I would
actually uh well when uh when uh Captain
duny talk speaks maybe he he might be
able to talk to us a little bit about
the rules if any rules would be would be
required for this or could be or whether
not this could be just done in rules but
might might it might might clear
something up but I don't know it might
answer your question okay thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question representative Coker
um can you just explain to me what
happens to the individual who is pulled
over by Marine Patrol and who has 48
hours to respond to a request for uh a
driver a voter's license Captain Dum
lovey would probably have a much better
answer I I know that you have 48 hours
to produce to produce your certificate
or your information that's that's yeah
that's about what I know um show up
somewhere and yeah yeah present yeah so
again this is just a real like it's it's
just trying to make things a little bit
clearer and and I know that the their
practice is already pretty like they
don't give people too much of a hard
time for not having it on them on their
person but this is just to clarify it
because when I the way that I read the
rules and I I kind of like to follow the
rules especially when I'm out on the
boat is I have to have that on me so I
try to keep it on me at all
times anyone
else seeing none have another question
out of curiosity how many B clubs are
there I know we've spoken about this
before are there are there several on
Lake wiip pasak I think there's a yeah I
think it it's sted to become more
popular um it's it's I I love it I mean
I don't I don't want to be an
advertisement right now but it's I think
it's gonna you're going to see more of
that in the future I
believe any more
questions very much all right thank
you Captain
dunlevy good afternoon Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is Tim Dunley and I come before you
this morning or this afternoon
representing the department of safety
Marine Patrol
unit and uh on behalf of the department
I wish to express to you that we are
taking a neutral position on this bill
uh we have uh spoken with representative
Coker about our wishes and our concerns
of just having the barcode as you all
have now seen on the back of the card
included and if I could uh just give a
little background on on the reasoning
for
that uh as many of you commit well been
quite a turnover with the committee but
uh in the past when when you folks as a
committee have been out on patrol boats
and seen us in action you'll see that
when our officer makes a boat stop their
number one priority is really to have
their hands on the boat that they've
stopped to prevent the boats from
banging into each other and causing
damage and doing a safety check and
having an exchange with the occupants of
that boat um is is a is a challenge
sometimes depending upon weather
condition and the size of the boat and
so on the office is then responsible for
documenting that contact with the public
it may be just a safety check they
stopped us wanting directions or perhaps
it's a ticket maybe even leads to an
arrest it's important for us to document
who we've dealt with during that time
and um anticipating technology and where
it has gone for officers on the road and
on the water we built in the barcode on
the back of these cards that is the
exact same barcode code on the back of
our driver's licenses those barcodes
allow us to take a handheld small
handheld scanner wave it over that
barcode and that immediately goes to our
laptops on the boats and uploads all
that person's personal information so
that it saves us the time from pushing
away driving a short distance away
riding on the high's legibly uh and then
returning to that boat all taking time
where now we can just scan this finish
our business with the occupants of the
boat and send them on their way saving a
significant amount of time less Boat
tobo contact everybody's a
winner right now the law says you are
required to carry your certificate with
you whenever you operate a boat greater
than 25
horsepower we recognize that people do
not carry this in their wallets all the
time like they do their driver's license
um because some days they may be on
their fishing boat ski Bo boat the next
day they could be in their grandparents
personal watercraft whatever it might be
these cards travel and sometimes they
don't travel with a person who may not
even be carrying their wallet because
it's in the glove box of the vehicle and
they're in their swim trunks out on the
water even though the law says you have
to have it we run into regularly people
who don't for a variety of reasons that
have no criminal intent behind them the
law then allows us to give that person
48 hours to provide us with the
information when we do that we have that
personto person contact and we say to
them please however you send this
information to us often times it's a
text a photo or an email we ask them to
include that
barcode uh and so that's why we uh work
with representative Coker to to include
that barcode language uh we realize
sometimes they come laminated in a photo
copy sometimes it's water log sometimes
it's you are allowed to buy as many
cards as you would like in your name um
so there are a variety of solutions but
for the solution that that comes before
you today um we're dealing with it now
we're accepting variations now we just
would include if it's going to go into
statute that that the language include
that
barcode I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have any
questions thank you Mr chair and thank
you Captain D lovey so if you're
accepting it now you're accepting
electronic copies now of it do you feel
like this legislation is not
needed um I would I would
um I would say that our common practice
is not going to result in anyone
receiving a ticket
today whether or not you folks wish to
move forward with this bill just to get
it in writing to ensure that that option
exists I I I would defer to you folks I
would understand either
way representative fail thank you Mr
chair uh thank you Captain for taking my
question so I'm just looking so I looked
at the card it went around it's a
certification for boater operation it's
not a
license correct that is
correct and so my question is are there
other safety certifications in the date
where we don't expect the person to
either carry it or we already have
digital access for perhaps the
department of safety or whoever is
involved I I know firsthand as far as
driver's license are concerned they do
not have that that option uh I can't
speak to other snowmobile registrations
or safety cards uh or or fishing game
hunting and fishing licenses what the
practice of those departments are I I
can't speak to them
sorry any representative D thank you Mr
chair thank you um for taking my
question um does the fiscal note here
says that the Department's going to lose
about $20,000 a year it looks like
there's 3,000 replacement cards $10 each
um it costs 10,000 to to print them is
that $20,000 going to be
impactful uh I must conf confess to you
sir that I don't know how they reached
that
$20,000 um I know that there is a
contract in place so that when people
get their cards those revenues that's
what those revenues are based
upon uh it's my belief that this bill is
not any way going to replace or cause
those revenues to drop because people
are going to get the card uh if if this
the language of this bill was to exempt
them from getting the card and just
providing us with an email saying they
pass the the the course we'd be talking
about a different story and then I
believe those those revenues would be
impacted or or a followup thank you Mr
chair
um as we just heard this isn't a license
but it is um you know a safety um sort
of a safety
certificate um one thing that some
people worry about when um when you have
copies is um fraud or um you know um
yeah fraud basically is there any have
is there any concern about fraud in cop
in copies of these safety
certificates uh we we're dealing that
with that now so whether it's a a an
electronic image or something we're
dealing with that on a regular basis now
um people are are doing their best even
with cards swapping them with relative
with there's no photo on it um there are
ways for us to to to to look at that um
representative wolf I passed around my
card he went to put my card in his
pocket when I reminded him my physical
description was a part of that barcode
he quickly handed it
over that's just one method by which we
can can ensure that and you yeah
sometimes it all slips with the cracks
but I I don't anticipate that being a
problem I have a suggestion what about
tattooing the barcod on your shoulder I
mean right on your forehead would be
okay that might have to go before a
different committee Health and Human
Services
sorry uh any other questions of the
captain representative H want go thank
you Mr chairman thank you Captain for
taking my question the uh voter safety
card is that for everybody on the boat
or just for the operator just for the
operator and just for the operator of a
boat over 2 horsepower currently the
statute exempts people who are operating
a boat that is less than 25 horsepower
from having to have the the card in the
course thank you yes sir anything else
anyone else
question your mic
on um I just got a dumb question um when
did you start us getting
these when did you start putting these
out uh the the
the legislature passed the mandatory
requirement for the course in 2000 was
effective 2001 so we're we're going into
24 25 years now oh okay I think mine
says since 2008 maybe I got it
later you need a
renewal no they promised we'd never have
to renew them that was one of the big
promises any uh yeah that's it anyone
else there any questions anyone else
seeing none very much thank you for your
time
I think that's
itd I I'd like to close the hearing is
that when they came to me I said okay
I'll do it right away and I did it I'm
sorry uh no I haven't I just now we're
over now not yet thank you very much now
it's
close uh five
minutes M we uh we have a we next bill
is 230 okay Mr chair question um I would
like to ask representative Coker that if
he could get us that Amendment um
whenever it's available to you just so
we have it in advance of our exec
session thank
you yeah I know there
was inquiry as far as uh you know doing
this you know executing this now but not
without the
amendment and
five
minutes
hello um for the record I'm will Derby
from nashal W Hillsboro District 11 I am
introducing House Bill 1554 in lie of
Representative makoni who's not
available please I am not available to
take any
questions
thank you again for allowing me to speak
on the Department of Environmental
Services regarding House Bill
1554 which affects the certified Calvert
maintainer program my name is darling
for the current Wetland SP
administrator the Culvert maintainer
program is a program that allows towns
to have one or two individuals within
the town precertify by passing a course
taught by uh professional development at
UNH to replace culverts up to 48 in in
diameter if you are a certified Culvert
maintainer you may replace these
culverts uh in kind or with a certain
amount of expansion in diameter up to
again that 40 in limit without obtaining
a permit in advance this allows town
dpws to maintain their assets with less
paperwork there is a reporting
requirement where the covert maintainer
does need to provide quarterly reports
outlining the covers that they have
maintained um many of these guys are in
the field they're not somebody who has a
desk in town with a laptop or a computer
on it which does make it difficult for
them to do their online reporting this
bill would provide for another
individual in town to file those reports
on behalf of their DPW crew so we're
hoping that it facilitates compliance
with the current reporting uh
requirements of this provision in
law we support this bill is there any
other is there any any any questions
from members of the committee
representative hgan thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh the person who fills out the
report does it matter who it is does it
have to be a public workp
technically at the moment whoever is the
certified cul maintainer is supposed to
be the person who files the report uh
this will change that so that it won't
matter who files the report as long as
report for that maintainer is received
so it could be you know if there are
three people in town who are certified
and they each give their reports to the
town clerk the town clerk could enter
the reports for all three they just need
to give them a list to report on their
behalf well followup and the individual
who is submitting the report does not
necessarily have to be a certified
individual they're just going to
consolidate information fill out of
reports and new fill out form correct
thank
you representative run thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so I'm assuming by the a
comment you just made Miss horse that
there's a problem with compliance with
people submitting the reports um but um
can you explain the value of the reports
like why is it important for DS to get
them is that who who receives a
report why why are the reports necessary
so Dees does receive these um by having
the quarterly reports it helps us update
our own records on what assets are out
there it does allow us to make sure we
understand that things have been
properly replaced with the appropriate
size not
downsized and if someone asks a question
as to if you're in a flood event and
something fails we can go back and see
what was LE recently replaced it is
actually a mechanism that many of these
towns use to replace their culverts
after flood events uh without an
emergency authorization or a permit
because if it was less than 48 in you
can replace it as a covert
maintainer without needing to get a
permit so it facilitates that we use the
records
to um help answer complaints or help
track maintenance and help update our
own records as well as there's a
database known as the sades database
which is a shared asset database that we
share with
Dot and other governmental agencies that
for um flood road
maintenance
coordination uh this helps
us with
that representative
Vale thank you Mr chair thank you for my
question um so I just wanted to reaffirm
this is covers that are 48 inches in
diameter and greater that are reported
on less or less except thank you this is
for culverts that are 48 inches and less
okay any Mar question representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you Miss
forest for uh taking my question um so
you mentioned this is for municipal um
employees it seems that there must be
other people that have to um repair CTS
like do how do those get reported and
are there any what about property owners
that um repair culs on their own on
their own land do do those get reported
as well so this is available for any um
governmental Agency State or
Municipal and it is not available this
particular process is not available to
individual homeowners but we do have
what is known as a statutory permit by
notification for routine roadway
driveway c replacement so there's a
one-page uh form with a 5-day turnaround
time and no filing fee that the
homeowners
use any other questions members of the
committee seeing
none
wait a
minute oh go ahead go ahead go ahead he
beat the
gav thank you Mr chair truly thank you
and also to the members of the committee
that are bearing with me here this the
bill though specifically added in the
language um such work in the
municipality so I wonder um I I'm just
trying to understand understand how the
covert replacements for the do at the
state level um it seems like that
wouldn't qualify under in the
municipality how those how those are
getting
reported if do uses this they just
report for the state or they report
through their Regional Offices since the
do does have Regional Offices they they
come in that
way going once going
twice I used I used to actually do
auctions but
anyway that's it
for that's it for the agenda I think
that's got through it we got through the
agenda I there
pardon uh
no for it's worth it's well we'll see
what saving him he didn't show up no
because he didn't show up
no hey look he's a chairman and he's old
I so I kind of I and I kind of identify
with
that yes
good
that